I got to come in this morning and say  you know they do care and and you feel  it when you have a live audience you  actually can feel them the bars whatever  it is the emotion coming ghosts it's  very exciting we've infiltrated people's  families and there are three generations  as we said on stage and we've got to  kind of if you meet us in person we've  got to live up to what's on screen I'm  just working on I do I'm still growing  you're part of their childhood so that  is an amazing honor it is actually magic  to see people take on the the kind of  what would you call it the ethos of the  film because you know JJ made like an  old-fashioned Star Wars film and then  these guys come in and and a part of it  and we're dragged along in the  slipstream but it's it's wonderful that  the legacy didn't end a few years ago  you